du modem la situation est très simple
les français devant des actes
gravissimes devant des actes de barbarie
veulent éprouver le sentiment que
justice a été rendue tout à fait
forcément la peine de mort mais ils
veulent que le tic on le revoit plus et
ça forcément content tu sais quand il
voit les chiffres n'est pas si on peut
remettre les listes des acquéreurs
incarcération de evrard voilà donc plus
courantes on voit voilà quand on voit 41
ans et que le type sort après vingt ans
les gens disent stop rétablissement de
la peine de mort c'est un réflexe de 15
dans la lah pauvres voilà encore un peu
tu restais démission à la reine de cette
pauvre monsieur sa permissivité demain
mais monsieur kg à la perpétuité de
demain ouais est ce que vous seriez dans
la même position sur la peine de mort
est ce que vous vous diriez pas il ya la
perpétuité
il sortira plus moi permis à mon avis
personnel 2007 ils avaient mon âge mon
avis laissez le parler je pense à lui
moi jusqu'à 2000 cette fois comme il est
dit s'affaler j'étais contraint mais
voilà quand je vois que ya pas de
solution que les choses qu'on m'a promis
ce même après mois après mon affaire on
a fait plein de rêves grâce à vous il y
aura des hôpitaux fermés même quand ils
auront fait leur peine nous avons dans
des hôpitaux ne sortir mais parce que si
à la perpétuité
les gens là fort différemment bien sûr
vous auriez pas seulement la grèce c'est
de changer les choses mais voilà que les
enfants fin ceinture et bretelles alors
s'il vous plaît c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de gens qui râlent chez soucis et
à plein de gens qui disent c'est vrai
que pour des peines moins graves
bien entendu que celle de francis evrard
lapin qui dit aussi qu'il ya des dégâts
et moi je connais plein voilà je vous le
dis je connais plein de garçons qui ont
fait de même dès disons dès 15 ans de
prison qui aujourd'hui sont dans la
réinsertion pour qu'une envie c'est
qu'au contraire c'est au contraire
vraiment et aider les autres c'est que
et aider les jeunes pour qui c'est pas
le même le même c'est le même avenir que
la mise au match aller les gamines
exactement ce ne sont pas des meurtres
il ya aussi
oui voilà la peine de mort des peines
dans tout le spectre et dans toute la
hiérarchie des peines et là où je vous
rejoins c'est qu'effectivement il ya le
problème des peines il ya le problème de
l'application des peines
c'est pas parce que certains on va
rétablir la peine de mort qu'on aura une
justice forcément qu'il appliquera quand
on voit que la justice est pas foutu
d'appliquer aujourd'hui les peines qui
existe c'est pas elle appliquera pas
forcément il est même très sûrement pas
qu'on fait dans tous les débats qu'on
fait dans balances ton post on se rend
compte à chaque fois quand on traite ces
sujets que le problème c'est moins la
police je sais - la sécurité que la
justice le gros problème en france
aujourd'hui je vous le dis je le redis
c'est la justice je suis déçu car il est
d'ailleurs la grande contradiction des
personnes qui sont favorables à la peine
de mort parce que qui va rendre ces
jugements peine de mort c'est la même
justice que vous avez que le véhicule
est sans cesse donc il ya une
contradiction regarder même aux états
unis depuis les années 70 y'a plus de
200 personnes dans le couloir de morts
qui ont été innocentés
rappelez-vous aussi pour moi on a
supprimé la peine de mort parce que
parce qu'il est julie tribunaux sont
failli non mais c'est vrai bien sûr ça
c'est de la raquette et curtis en
souterrain si on arrive à billets à
peine de mort nous enverrons à
l'échafaud ça ces personnes qui n'ont
rien fait 30 ans que d'y répondre le
modèle américain qu'il en attendait
environ je vous parle de la ferrage et
les juges en france maintenant comme
dans tous les autres
oui mais je et par foyer contre la
fougue oui mais la france d'en bas les
états unis on vous donne une galerie de
l'ex de justin et selena même geste ans
la france a prévu des coupes et attend
des halls peut parler ces chutes en
sable il ya des gens qui nous écoutent
j'ai envie de comprendre le débat
arrêtez de couper en deux et un rabbin
ici
merci oui
un compliment mais la plus grande
faiblesse implique la plus grande
intransigeance
alors laquelle je suis donc je disais on
parle depuis tout à l'heure on dit qu'il
ya une aspiration à la justice de la
part de nos compatriotes et je pense que
c'est vrai mais au-delà de ça il ya le
cas particulier de la perversion
pédophiles d'accord qui est incurable et
c'est ça parce que quand on parle de
réhabilitation d'insertion même pour des
personnes qui ont fait des choses
horribles en réalité peut y avoir des
parcours de vie en prison et des sorties
qui sont mêmes les remises par exemple
elle s'en fait aussi pour ça il ya une
logique les personnes qui gèrent les
prisonniers vous diront que l'espoir de
partir plus tôt à favoriser un certain
comportement etc
mais il ya la difficulté singulière de
ce type de crime là où c'est pas
incurable et dans d'autres pays par
exemple via la castration chimique
c'est vrai que on est en retard là
dessus en france parce que y'a vous avez
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques en
france des personnes qui sont à vis
notamment parmi les personnes qui sont
déclarées irresponsables comme on dit
pour pour pour être jugé eh ben vous
faut pas penser qu'il parte dans la rue
le lendemain deux camps et quand ils
sont déclarés comme ça et responsable
eelv ont en réalité dans les hôpitaux
est souvent ici ici il y décède il et
décède ça existe en france des gens qui
décèdent dans les hôpitaux psy capture
mais c'est vrai que nous n'avons pas la
castration chimique
et ça pourrait être une solution
d'autant que je crois même
et alors je peux me tromper il faut il
faut vérifier mais je crois même que
dans le cas evra il ya un moment donné
où il a demandé alors justement regard
des ondes à l'image evra de bordés a
demandé à se faire soigner vous le savez
mustapha regarder pendant le procès ça
tombe bien qui vous est interdit de
fréquenter et de rencontrer des mineurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous allez
vous occuper
de faire le lasser de ce petit garçon de
5 ans et ça vaut bien quelque chose qui
se déclenche en bloc et qui a personne
qui agit en effet quelques jours
justement monsieur j'ai toujours été
pour y être soigné aux mots que j'étais
arrêté est ce que j'avais on m'a
autorisé à se soigner
on m'a dit oh la prison le prêt il faut
à la prison puis j'ai tout on n'a pas
revu qu'on ne dis pas que je ne dois
puis sortir je suis pas une bête
c'est incroyable ça va de la justice et
cahiers 10 heures bien sûr il ya deux
voies d être soigné on la passera des
contenants dans ses calculs il peut rien
une émission spéciale et si mustapha sur
son avant dernière peine qu'il a pris
une émission sur m6 et qu'ils ont fait
dans la prison il est incarcéré
il dit bien parce qu'il voulait une
permission pour sortir à ce moment là
quand il veut une permission il prend
ses cachets ces médicaments pour se
soigner
mais quand on lui a refusé sa permission
il dit bien aux médecins la barre et ça
a été filmé pourrait trouver donc que
cette émission là il dit bien à moi ça
m'intéresse pas moi que telus pour
sortir dehors et j'ai pas j'ai pas envie
de me faire soigner
et quand il est sorti quand de sa de sa
dernière peine
pourquoi il demande de viagra je veux
dire c'est bien que de faire soigner et
ça le courrier c'était juste son avocat
qu'il est de faire comme ça pour
attendrir pour dire que c'est d'état le
fautif et non lui mais il n'est pas
malade ce mec-là c'est lui c'est sa
tendance sexuelle et c'est tout et parce
que c'est des enfants ils sont innocents
ils savent pas dire non et ça peut
s'exprimer c'est un lâche pourquoi ya
pas le faire à moi
moi je crache ses deux jambes et sa tête
pourquoi ne fais pas moi c'est tout il
s'en prend dé il préférable
non mais alors alors il ya beaucoup de
réactions je veux que je veux dire dans
un instant christine après on aura beau
monsieur qui veut rajouter quelque chose
qui jouera le jeu de nuit ce que je veux
dire que ça reflète quand même ce que 55
% reflète l'état de la société
d'aujourd'hui ne cessa pour reprendre un
mot très à la mode darmanin qui n'est
pas employé par moretti
c'est le mot d'ensauvagement et
pompon qui voit là les français
ressentent
justement cette insécurité faut quand
même rappeler que c'est pas parce qu'on
a une insécurité on te vole ta voiture
ont bien tu as cassé j'en sais rien on
va des cinquièmes en correctionnelle les
assises et ce qui est susceptible que
pourraient être susceptibles d'être
saoul à la condamnation de la peine de
mort ça serait plus de huit ans de
prison c'est à dire que ce serait très
très rare et la peine de mort ne
pourrait pas répondre à cette ce
sentiment d'ensauvagement de
l'association d'accord alors je lis
rajouter quelque chose on arrive à
prendre agents mais oui je voudrais
ajouter un truc sympa on vous dira
l'article 700 du code pénal prévoit un
crédit de réduction de peine de trois
mois pour la première année de deux mois
pour les années qui filent et de sept
jours par mois
et c'est pas bon c'est pas fait pour
tout pour tous pour tous et le dis que
c'est bien mais et je vous précise que
tout miracle mais c'est mr alain
carignon non pour dire moi le rêve à moi
deux mois et sept jours parce que c'est
un jour par mois la première année
durant toute la peine d christiane
taubira ne vous voyez que c'est pas une
connerie dont christiane taubira dit
quand elle est garde des sceaux qu'elle
applique cette mesure aux récidivistes
ce qui n'était pas le cas et donc ça
réduit la peine des récidivistes de
l'ordre de 20%
ça les français ne le supporte plus pas
plus tard qu il ne le supporte bien que
des 20% de peines de moins
c'est pour ça que certains sont
exaspérés oui et demande des mesures
aussi forte l'apaisement si on disait
aux récidivistes peine incompressible
noir pour des crimes d'enfants
perpétuité pettitte durée mais moins de
france et pour la peine de mort bah
écoutez c'est que ça ne passait pas
c'est parce qu'ils aient concours ce
qu'on constate parce que même en 81
quand la peine de mort a été abolie il y
avait encore énormément de français qui
était content plaide presque plus que
60%
d'après ce qu'on entend dans l'armée je
reviens sur la comparaison avec le
modèle américain j'entends depuis tout à
l'heure la comparaison avec le modèle
américain alors que la france est
singulièrement différent cette
comparaison totalement fallacieuses et
trompeuse ya trois différences majeures
avec les états unis
d'abord aux états unis vous avez un
problème avec les armes à feu il ya
énormément d'armes à feu en circulation
la deuxième différence avec la france
c'est qu'aux états unis
vous avez une ségrégation raciale
non-officiel c'était là vous avez plus
de chance de vous faire condamner
à mort quand vous êtes noir que quand
vous êtes blanc c'est le système qui
veut ça il ya aussi un problème de
moyens de défense plus vous avez
d'argent aux états unis plus vous
arrivez à vous d'en sortir
et enfin vous avez également le parrain
de la voile arrêter de le couper comme
dirait zéribi monsieur marc donc
terrible aussi ça l'enfer alesi à
l'émission médias le la de la troisième
différence c'est le pacte social posé
aux etats unis c'est vraiment le pays
par excellence du marche ou crève ya
aucune aide d'aucune sorte
il ya un degré d'inégalité sociale
absolument phénoménale un taux de très
grande pauvreté en france qu'on le
veuille ou non nous avons quand même un
état qui prend soin des citoyens du
berceau à la tombe il ya un nombre
incalculable n'est donc effectivement
plus nous avons un état providence qui
couvrent qui protège les gens - la
violence est supportable du c'est d'une
certaine façon
donc arrêtez de comparer avec les états
unis s'est pas du tout la mi temps mais
ça